Anson Wong is a
wildlife trafficker.
He's also a guy who was
trafficking at the time
all the things we care about
when we think about
precious wildlife.
He was offering
snow leopard pelts
rhino horn,
he was moving live elephants.
He had a tiger farm in Vietnam
where they raised tigers
killed them, mounted them
as taxidermy specimens
sold them as trophies for people
to put in their living rooms.
He had this Spix's Macaw.
It's a bird that's supposed
to be extinct in the wild.
Anson was offering three
for $100,000 apiece.
The US Fish and Wildlife service
considered him in the 90s
the biggest international
wildlife trafficker
in the world.
They launched an investigation
called "Operation Chameleon".
And it was successful.
When he got out of jail,
he went immediately back
to the reptile business.
I also know from talking
to reptile traders
he was never out
of business.
While he was in jail,
his wife was trading for him.
So, we came up with
another operation
we called it
"Operation Big Ego".
So, I learned his techniques
and then I went to Indonesia
where his major customers
and competitors are
and I lived on a
reptile breeding farm
and met as many of his
competitors and...
clients, as possible.
Then I flew to Malaysia.
And I didn't know what
Anson looked like.
I said-- I walked into the
shop, 22-B, Jones Road
and I-- there are two Chinese
guys standing in the doorway
I said, they said...
"Can we help you?"
I said, "Yeah, I'm
looking for Anson Wong."
And then the same guy
said, "I'm Anson Wong."
I said,
"Oh, I'm Bryan Christy."
He said,
"I've heard of you.
I hear you're writing
about Strictly Reptiles.
What you should really be
doing is writing about me.
I'm much bigger."
And that...
is when Operation Big Ego
really took off.
( audience laughter )
And he, and he said not
only that but "look"
and he slid
a stack of blueprints
across the desk to me.
I said, "What's this?"
He said, "A tiger farm.
I'm building a tiger park
here on Penang Island.
And the government
is funding me."
So, this is the world's
leading wildlife trafficker
arrested in the United States.
He returns, his own government
funds him to build a tiger park
this is a guy who is
trafficking in tigers.
I said, "I have a story."
The story was called
"The Kingpin".
This story ran in Malaysia.
Within weeks law
enforcement officials
raided Anson--
Anson's facilities
they stripped him off
his business license
his license to move
endangered species.
Members of parliament took
that literal magazine
and held it on the floor of
parliament and demanded change.
Malaysian parliament passed
the first new reform legislation
for wildlife in 40 years.
That summer,
Anson was arrested.
And he was tried
and convicted
sentenced to
six months in prison.
The public outcry over a
six month prison was so great
that the government effectively
appealed its own victory
retried him
and he was sentenced to
five years in prison.
A massive penalty...
in any country in the world.
The prosecutor and the
judge held up this story
and said,
"This is what we're doing."